je vais d'abord vous dire que ce campus
n'aurait pas eu lieu sans travail durant
tous les thés d'une formidable équipe de
jeunes autour de toi cher Tristan
c'est grâce à eux c'est grâce à vous que
nous sommes rassemblés ce weekend alors
vous pouvez les applaudir bien fort
je vous remercie également Stéphane
piennois sénateur président de la
fédération du Maine-et-Loire qui nous
accueille ce weekend à Angers
cher Annie chers présidente merci merci
pour ton soutien si précieux pour cet
événement auquel tu le sais nous tenons
le temps nous les jeunes républicains
j'ai aussi une pensée reconnaissante
pour Christian Jacob notre ancien
président
qui a permis la refondation du mouvement
jeune il y a maintenant deux ans en nous
accordant notre autonomie
et puis si vous me le permettez je veux
dire un mot pour Laurent Wauquiez
il y a quelques mois maintenant Laurent
était venu me soutenir pour ma campagne
législative dans le Tarn et je me
souviens qu'au départ de Laurent Jeanine
et militante tarnaise historique qui a
participé à attendre campagne
fidèle parmi les fidèles m'avait dit en
sortant dieu seul sait si je serai là en
2027 mais grâce à Laurent je gardais
espoir pour mon pays voilà la promesse
se réveille français à mes amis
mes amis trois trois Français sur 4 se
disent pessimistes en pensant à leur
avenir mais pour le président de la
République tout va bien
un imam fiché s notoirement dangereux
antisémite misogyne qui prêchent devant
des dizaines de milliers de jeunes sur
les réseaux sociaux
expulsables qui disparaît dans la nature
mais tout va bien
la moitié de nos réacteurs nucléaires
qui sont à l'arrêt des coupures
d'électricité promise pour cet hiver
mais tout va bien
à Lyon à la Guillotière on lance des
policiers qui procédaient à une
interpellation mais tout va bien
en 40 ans en 40 ans la France a reculé
du quatrième rang économique à la 7e
place mais tout va bien
[Musique]
monsieur Macron nomme à l'éducation
nationale un ministre racialiste
oubliant le discours de Gambetta du 14
juillet 1872 la République ne serait
qu'un mensonge sans une éducation
véritablement nationale sans la défense
de la patrie sans l'application
rigoureuse de la souveraineté nationale
sans attaques par jour au couteau mais
monsieur Macron reconduit un ministre de
la Justice pour lequel la France n'est
pas un coup de gorge monsieur Macron
reconduit également un ministre de
l'Économie champion des impôts des taxes
de la dette des déficits publics
commerciaux sociaux et de l'avantardise
mais tout va bien
pour conserver le pouvoir il utilise la
vieille ficelle mitterrandienne
la peur le chaos résultat il a fait lire
sur les bancs au siège Jean Jaurès et
Clémenceau des ennemis de la République
et de la nation les députés qui se
prétendent d'un soumis mais en réalité
dominé par leur électorat
communautarisme des députés français
soumises qui préfèrent marcher contre
l'islamophobie avec la filiale en France
des Frères musulmans mais étonnamment
silencieux devant l'attentat devant
l'attentat Visan Salman Rushdie des
députés écologistes enfants des 68
heures qui voulaient interdire ce qui
était interdit et qui maintenant veulent
supprimer la viande dans les cantines le
barbecue une affaire trop virile
le Tour de France les piscines les
sapins de Noël et les Miss France les
joyeux baba cool de Mai 68 sont devenus
de bien tristes inquisiteurs à droite
nous revendiquons une écologie du bon
sens
s'appuyer naturellement chez Bruno sur
notre filière d'excellence nucléaires
investir massivement dans l'hydrogène
accélérer la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments pour en finir avec ses 5
millions de passoires thermiques oui la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
est un formidable enjeu pour nous
nous voulons faire de la transition
écologique la grande révolution
industrielle du 21e siècle
mes amis je crois que les Français sont
fatigués des discours politiques ils
croient plus en politique à quoi
sert-elle si le pouvoir donne tous les
signes de l'impuissance face à la
Commission européenne qui a laissé
ouverte l'Europe à tous les vents de la
mondialisation provoquant délocalisation
destruction notre appareil productif
attaque en règle de notre modèle
agricole par des ONG financés
subventionnés par Bruxelles une
mondialisation sauvage qui appauvrit les
classes moyennes et classes populaires
l'impuissance également face à des juges
qui vont chercher dans des textes
européens de quoi casser toute politique
de contrôle migratoire la souveraineté
nationale pour Monsieur Macron c'est
fini c'est terminé il ne parle plus que
de souveraineté européenne à l'image de
ces élites qui ont fait un trait
définitif sur nos frontières sur notre
peuple sur notre nation
une délinquance qui explose chez Eric et
dont on veut taire les causes une
immigration massive l'échec de
l'intégration le refus de l'assimilation
la montée du communautarisme et de
l'islamisme une justice qui n'a pas les
moyens de sa mission et qui donne des
signes de laxisme parmi nous mes amis
Hanane ils veulent vous pouvez les
applaudir
Milito en Isère militant à Grenoble qui
est en soir se sont fait tabasser il y a
quelques semaines par des milices
d'extrême gauche la peine prononcée
contre leurs agresseurs quelques heures
de travail d'intérêt général est-ce que
c'est ça la justice
[Musique]
on s'est targué d'avoir le meilleur
système de santé au monde il a fallu une
crise pour s'apercevoir que l'hôpital
public était à genoux et que les
soignants n'en pouvaient plus le niveau
des écoliers baisse l'école est devenue
la matrice la fabrique des inégalités la
bureaucratie paralyse l'état l'essentiel
reste décidé depuis Paris par une
technocratie sans racine
mes amis pour ceux qui allaient voter
comme pour tous les autres un même
sentiment le pouvoir n'appartient plus à
ce que le suffrage universel a désigné
alors il ne suffira pas demain de
reprendre le pouvoir il faudra l'exercer
en faisant souhaiter tous les verrous
qui paralysent l'action publique avec
une seule obsession bien sûr l'intérêt
français l'intérêt national que les
Français retrouvent l'espérance et que
la France retrouve sa grandeur car l'une
ne va pas sans l'autre
mes amis la France ce n'est pas une page
blanche
nous autres civilisations savon que nous
sommes mortelles écrivait Paul Valéry
prenons garde tant de grandes
civilisations disparu nous sommes les
héritiers de la civilisation grécolatine
la citoyenneté romaine l'organisation de
la cité par les Grecs nous sommes les
héritiers la civilisation
judéo-chrétienne pas une commune sur son
clocher la liberté et l'égalité selon
saint Paul ce formidable exercice
d'introspection chez Mountain dans ses
Essais la recherche douloureuse de Dieu
chez Pascal l'ironie cinglante de
Voltaire à l'égarder puissants et sa
dénonciation du fanatisme religieux
Napoléon à la fois génie militaire
et chez ni dans la construction de
l'État moderne
la France ce sont ces carottes
légionnaires qui dans une hacienda
Cameron se sont battus contre 2000
cavaliers
la France ce sont ses parents du 8e
RPIMA de Castres tombé dans la vallée en
Afghanistan
mort pour la France mort pour notre
liberté
mais la France ce sont aussi ces héros
du quotidien c'est cette maman tarnaise
qui élève seule ses enfants et qui
m'avoué manger un jour sur deux pour
assurer les repas quotidiens de ses
enfants la France ce sont ses pompiers
ses professeurs ces policiers ses
soignants ces caissières ces essentiels
pour lesquelles la politique ne change
plus rien
mes amis je sais pourquoi vous vous êtes
engagés vous aimez la France vous voulez
la servir
et parfois
l'état de notre pays vous désespère
parfois vous n'y croyez plus
mais pourtant je veux qu'ensemble
aujourd'hui à Angers on fasse le serment
de ne jamais rien lâcher il n'y a pas de
fatalité non il n'y a pas de fatalité
même pour celui qui en 43 regarder la
mort en face ceux qui ont gagné sont
ceux qui n'ont jamais plié qui n'ont
jamais renoncé et qui ont toujours
espéré cette espérance c'est la nôtre
alors vive la république et nous la
France
[Applaudissements]